so Andrew Tate tweeted that reading  books is for losers who are afraid to  learn from life so instead of learning  from Life they try to learn from the  lives others have lived this is so  absurd multiple types of learning are  useful and important there are lots of  things that you can better learn by  doing for example to me I never learned  to play drums by reading about playing  drums I took lessons and I practiced and  I play drums and I had drumming books as  well but they had exercises great that's  one way to learn if I want to learn  about perseverance one of the great ways  to learn about perseverance would be to  read about the lives of people no longer  alive in the past who persevered there's  no way to take that experience and learn  about it by doing I can learn to  persevere in other ways in my life but  some things books really are the best  way